A basketball coach has
20 players available.
Out of them, he needs to choose
five for the starting
lineup, and seven who would
be sitting on the bench.
In how many ways can the coach
choose these 5 plus 7 players?
It is certainly a huge number,
but what exactly is it?
In this lecture, we will
learn how to answer
questions of this kind.
More abstractly, we will develop
methods for counting
the number of elements of a
given set which is described
in some implicit way.
Now, why do we care?
The reason is that in many
models, the calculation of
probabilities reduces
to counting.
Counting the number of elements
of various sets.
Suppose that we have a
probability model in which the
sample space, Omega, is finite,
and consists of n
equally likely elements.
So each element has
probability 1/n.
Suppose now that we're
interested in the probability
of a certain set, A, which
has k elements.
Since each one of the elements
of A has probability 1/n, and
since A has k distinct
elements, then by the
additivity axiom, the
probability of A is equal to k
times 1 over n.
Therefore to find the
probability of A, all we have
to do is to count the number of
elements of Omega and the
number of elements of A,
and so determine the
numbers k and n.
Of course, if a set is described
explicitly through a
list of its elements, then
counting is trivial.
But when a set is given
through some abstract
description, as in our
basketball team example,
counting can be a challenge.
In this lecture, we will start
with a powerful tool, the
basic counting principle, which
allows us to break a
counting problem into
a sequence of
simpler counting problems.
We will then count permutations,
subsets,
combinations, and partitions.
We will see shortly what all
of these terms mean.
In the process we will solve a
number of example problems,
and we will also derive the
formula for the binomial
probabilities, the probabilities
that describe
the number of heads
in a sequence of
independent coin tosses.
So, let us get started.